[Music]
a hostile artificial intelligence called
NIM has taken over the world's computers
you're the only person skilled enough to
shut it down and you'll only have one
chance you've broken into NIMS secret
lab and now you're floating in a raft on
top of 25 stories of electrified water
you've rigged up a remote that can lower
the water level by ejecting it from
grates in the sides of the room if you
can lower the water level to zero you
can hit the manual override shut NIM off
and save the day however the AI knows
that you're here and it can lower the
water level too by sucking it through a
trapdoor at the bottom of the lab if NIM
is the one to lower the water level to
zero you'll be sucked out of the lab
resulting in a failed mission control
over water drainage alternates between
you and NIM and neither can skip a turn
each of you can lower the water level by
exactly 1 3 or 4 stories at a time
whoever gets the level exactly to zero
on their turn will win this deadly duel
note that neither of you can lower the
water level below zero if the water
level is at 2 then the only move is to
lower the water level one story you know
that NIM has already computed all
possible outcomes of the contest and
will play in a way that maximizes its
chance of success you go first
how can you survive and shut off the
artificial intelligence
you can't leave anything up to chance
NIMH will take any advantage it can get
and you'll need to have a response to
any possible move it makes the trick
here is to start from where you want to
end and work backwards you want to be
the one to lower the water level to zero
which means you need the water level to
be at one three or four when control
switches to you if the water level were
at two your only option would be to
lower it one story which would lead to
NIMH making the winning move if we color
code the water levels we can see a
simple principle at play there are
losing levels like to where no matter
what whoever starts their turn there
does they'll lose and there are winning
levels where whoever starts their turn
there can either win or leave their
opponent with a losing level so not only
are one three and four winning levels
but so are five and six since you can
send your opponent to two from there
what about seven from seven all possible
moves would send your opponent to a
winning level making this another losing
level
and we can continue up the lab in this
way if you start your turn one three or
four levels above a losing level then
you're at a winning level otherwise
you're destined to lose you could
continue like this all the way to level
25 but as a shortcut you might notice
that levels 8 through 11 are colored
identically to 1 through 4 since a
levels color is determined by the levels
1 3 & 4 stories below it this means that
level 12 will be the same color as level
5 13 will match 6 14 will match 7 and so
on in particular the losing levels will
always be multiple of 7 and 2 greater
than multiples of 7 now from your
original starting level of 25 you have
to make sure your opponent starts on a
losing level every single turn if NIM
starts on a winning level even once it's
game over for you so your only choice on
turn one is to lower the water level by
4 stories no matter what the AI does you
can continue giving it losing levels
until you reach 0 and trigger the manual
override and with that the crisis is
averted now back to a less stressful
kind of surfing here's a bonus riddle
where you can use similar skills in a
deadly and delicious duel here's how it
works
you and your opponent will take turns
eating squares from a chocolate bar each
turn you must choose a square that will
be the lower left corner of a rectangle
that you have to break off and eat every
square is safe to eat except the lower
left one of the whole bar which is
poisonous so if you're playing with a
2x3 bar and you go first
what should your first move be to
survive this bonus riddle comes courtesy
of our sponsor brilliant org brilliance
content is guided by a great set of
principles including curating content
that excites cultivates curiosity and is
active rather than passive check out
brilliant today at brilliant org slash
ted-ed and the first 833 of you will get
off the annual subscription fee and to
confirm your answer to the bonus riddle
sign up for a free membership by
clicking the link below and brilliant
will email you the solution